your [ __ ] fall it is sometimes it is  but no no no no it's always your fault  literally accountability is the quickest  path to being happy it's a curveball  because people love to blame someone  else because it feels good in the moment  but if you go the other way and you're  like it's all on me over a period of  time you'll realize how awesome that is  I appreciate you calling out  accountability it might be friends world  the first character I'm going to write  about for six-year-olds is accountable  Aunt because I think if I could teach  kids accountability early on that that's  cool and good instead of what the  world's done for the last 30 years in  modern parenting which is blame  everybody else but themselves I think we  can have a happier world  [Applause]